نعم جيم ما نتعلمه هو أن
هذا الهجوم حدث عند إحدى
بوابات الدخول تلك التي تناقشتم يا رفاق أن
بوابات الدخول هذه قد
اجتاحها الأفغان خلال
الأيام القليلة الماضية على مدار الأيام العشرة الماضية بصراحة في
محاولة للوصول إلى المطار
يشرح سبب سماعنا أن
هناك ضحايا أفغان نتيجة
لهذا الانفجار الآن قيل لنا أن هذا
الانفجار يبدو وكأنه هجوم انتحاري
كان شيئًا من
المحتمل أن يكون شخصًا ما قد وقع فيه ولكننا
نتطلع إلى معرفة المزيد عن ذلك ولكن
تم إغلاق هذه البوابات بشكل كبير
في الأيام القليلة الماضية حيث
أعطت الولايات المتحدة الأولوية لدخول الأمريكيين
ولكن الأفغان لا يزالون في
حشود كبيرة خارج هذه البوابات مما
جعل الوضع في المطار حيث كانت
الحكومة الأمريكية تتعقب تنظيم الدولة الإسلامية.  ك
تهديد خطير بشكل لا يصدق
وسمعنا هذا الصباح من كبار
الدبلوماسيين الأمريكيين على الأرض في أفغانستان
الذي لم يتحدث عن التهديد المحدد
التدفقات التي كانت الولايات المتحدة
تلتقطها ، لكنه استخدم كلمة
وشيكة لوصف التهديدات التي
يرونها والتي هي ممكنة
بالطبع ما نراه الآن
هو شيء كانوا على الأرجح
يتتبعونه بشكل عام ، لذا
سيكون هذا أمرًا لا يصدق.
تطور سريع للوضع نتطلع
إلى معرفة المزيد حول ما إذا كان هناك أي ضحايا أو
أصيب أي شخص من الجانب الأمريكي حتى
الآن لم يكن هناك ضحايا لنا
تم إخبارنا
ولكننا سنراقب أيضًا لنرى كيف
يؤثر ذلك على جهود الإخلاء في الولايات المتحدة
لا يزالون يسافرون بالأمريكيين إلى
خارج البلاد ، وقد حذروا هؤلاء الأمريكيين
من الابتعاد عن هذه البوابات
بالأمس فقط بسبب تيار التهديد
الذي كانوا يشاهدونه ولكن
ما نتعلمه الآن هو أن هذا كان عند إحدى
بوابات الدخول إلى المطار
و  يشتبه في أنه هجوم انتحاري